nos encontramos en la ciudad de odessa
donde a esta hora vuelven a sonar las
alarmas pero la noticia está a 135
kilómetros al este de aquí en la
población de mica live donde anoche una
base militar fue atacada y más de 40
soldados habrían muerto según las
informaciones aunque a esta hora siguen
buscando bajo los escombros este ataque
es bastante importante porque mi calor
se ha convertido en ese escudo que
protege a la ciudad de odessa las
fuerzas rusas han llegado a abordarlo
por el norte el este y el sur sin
embargo la presión de las fuerzas
ucranianas en los últimos días los
habían hecho retroceder y hablando con
el alcalde de la ciudad dio de esa hace
pocos minutos nos decía que los rusos
estaban cambiando la estrategia y
estaban utilizando tanto sus aviones
como esos misiles enviados por ejemplo
desde la isla de crimea para atacar a
esta población y debilitar la que como
decíamos es fundamental para la defensa
dio de esa que es la joya de la corona
en esta parte del sur del país